[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saludos juliet riaño
[Música]
las cifras de los menores migrantes que
llegan solos a eeuu continúa aumentando
hasta la semana pasada unos 11.000 niños
no acompañados estaban bajo custodia del
departamento de salud y servicios
humanos el dato más alto registrado
desde 2019 en esa dependencia
la mayoría son adolescentes pero un buen
número tiene menos de 12 años
recordemos que el gobierno biden dijo
que no expulsaría a los menores que
emigraron solos por lo que ahora los
niños esperan una respuesta en
territorio estadounidense
ante tal llegada surgen dudas sobre el
trato hacia los menores en los polémicos
centros de recepción que fueron
reabiertos por la administración bailén
para dar respuesta el gobierno le abrió
las puertas de uno de estos sitios a los
medios y a un grupo de congresistas
[Música]
son menores que viajaron solos sin un
familiar hasta eeuu
en este centro de procesamiento en
carrizo springs texas hay unos 750
menores entre 13 y 17 años hoy se le
permitió a un equipo con cámaras acceder
a este lugar es la primera vez que el
gobierno le abre las puertas a la prensa
para verificar la situación de los niños
durante su paso por estas instalaciones
el permiso fue una respuesta a estas
fotografías presentadas por el
congresista por texas henry cuéllar las
imágenes fueron tomadas en un centro de
procesamiento en dona y se veía a niños
en el suelo tapados con mantas de
aluminio en habitaciones improvisadas y
es que centros como estos fueron
reabiertos por el gobierno de byd en
luego de recibir críticas durante la
administración trump por ser el
epicentro de la polémica durante la
separación de miles de familias
la norma dice que los niños deben
permanecer en sitios como estos máximo
durante 72 horas pero la realidad es
otra el acelerado aumento de las
llegadas ha colapsado la capacidad de
las agencias del gobierno rondando el
tiempo de estadía hasta las 130 horas
estamos enviando un mensaje muy claro
que la gente debe quedarse en la región
estamos estableciendo canales legales
para emigrar tampoco vamos a devolver a
un niño de 5 años a méxico por sí solo y
por eso vamos a cumplir con la ley nos
entregamos tan rápido como podamos al
departamento de salud para reunirlos con
su familia o su patrocinador y puedan
buscar asilo en la visita de los medios
y congresistas se ve que los menores
cuentan con los servicios elementales
pero lo cierto es que este centro no
está ubicado en la frontera donde los
menores son recibidos inicialmente hay
una mejora respecto a lo que vi durante
la pasada administración sin embargo hay
que hacer mucho más creo que tenemos que
trabajar más para asegurar que
conectamos a estos niños con sus
familias hay muchas razones por las que
eso tiene que ocurrir rápidamente ahora
el gobierno ha dicho estar preocupado
ante el gran número de menores que
llegan solos hasta eeuu
pero realmente están los niños migrando
solos hacia eeuu funcionarios del
gobierno y defensores de los migrantes
reconocen que el aumento se debe en
parte al cambio de política de bailén
sobre los menores la realidad de este
tránsito demuestra la desesperación de
las familias por un futuro mejor para
ellos pero también revela el negocio de
los contrabandistas que acompañan el
peligroso viaje
en el tránsito hacia eeuu por
centroamérica es común ver a niños
caminando sin compañía de sus familias
la historia de su viaje en solitario es
diferente en cada caso algunos pasan por
territorios peligrosos en mexico al
cuidado únicamente de traficantes hay
algunos que efectivamente según hemos
detectado pues vienen acompañados o son
traídos por algún pollero cuando vienen
no acompañados pues es más inclusiva
acompañado las familias de alguna manera
traen un un guía le llaman ellos pero en
realidad se trata de personas que les
cobraron por traerlas hasta este punto
imposible cruzar los eeuu entonces es
algo es algo que definitivamente pues
queremos desincentivar qué es lo que
ellos mismos se den cuenta que no que no
es cierto que está pasando ahorita los
viajes con contrabandistas cuestan miles
de dólares y en su mayoría son
financiados por familiares que están en
eeuu a las organizaciones de ayuda les
preocupa que los padres estén enviando a
sus hijos solos para que se les permita
el ingreso eeuu aclaró que si bien está
aceptando a los migrantes que tuvieron
que esperar en méxico bajo el protocolo
de protección al migrante
pepe las puertas no están abiertas para
todos hay gente que dice es que traigo
menores y tengo que cruzar no es cierto
ahorita está lo del programa en pipí y
aún así ellos todavía ni siquiera pueden
ingresar o la mayoría va entonces
lamentablemente los polleros están
utilizando toda esta información para
poderle sacar dinero a ellos va pero no
está entrando gente que no esté en el
programa en pp muchos niños que dicen
estar viajando solos estarían entrando
con otros miembros de sus familias que
no son sus tutores y los contrabandistas
aprovecharían la situación para usarlos
como señuelo en operaciones de
contrabando de drogas
los menores migrantes suponen el primer
reto político para joe biden el éxodo
pone a prueba la capacidad de la
administración para procesar de forma
segura a los niños hasta que inmigrantes
de france24 seguiremos cubriendo la
actualidad de la migración en américa
latina y en el mundo en todas sus
facetas los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 sigan con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]